México un infierno para los migrantes
cientos de personas provenientes
principalmente de Venezuela Honduras y
Guatemala intentan cruzar el río Bravo
en colchones inflables soñando con un
mejor futuro en Estados Unidos llevan
semanas en territorio mexicano esperando
una cita para obtener el estatus de
refugiados por el gobierno
estadounidense sin embargo los migrantes
alegan que la aplicación móvil para
solicitar citas no funciona y se dicen
cansados de su Calvario en el país
Azteca
de esto
prácticamente durmiendo en la calle
con mi hijo me meto una aplicación no
funciona
diversas instituciones que velan por los
Derechos Humanos argumentan que el
gobierno encabezado por Andrés Manuel
López Obrador utiliza el Instituto
Nacional de Migración para contener a
los migrantes a través de detenciones y
tratos que violan los Derechos Humanos
Mira el desempeño del Instituto Nacional
de Migración ha sido bien
Cómo puedo decir yo negligente
porque se supone que ellos tienen ellos
siempre promueven de lo que es la
migración Segura
segura ordenada y regular algo que no
cumplen porque el trato que da la misma
migración a las personas migrantes ha
sido de violencia violatorio como
sabemos de Derechos Humanos
México Había sido catalogado como un
país de tránsito para los flujos
migratorios una condición que cambió
consecuencia de la nueva política
migratoria adoptada por el gobierno
mexicano la actitud del gobierno de Joe
biden hacia los migrantes del sur y su
política de quédense en México podría
ser el detonante de este cambio de rumbo